and the best bombing oh man
it's still i still bomb and it
it is such a weird like it feels good
to know that it can still happen yeah
because if you don't if you don't bomb
after a while you're not challenging
yourself
you're not trying i like that oh i know
this i know this formula works and i'll
give people a formula
people get [ __ ] sick of a formula
i'll tell you that you could watch joke
writers you could watch seinfeld you
don't learn anything about seinfeld's
life
from watching seinfeld's comedy but
that's that's joke writing that's what
you need
first right you know you need you need
that skill
and then you could take that skill and
apply it to your
actual life and that i think is where
you
start to find your voice because you're
like oh this is a situation that
actually happened to me
at the store or in a relationship so
it's truth i'm talking my truth
but i also have this skill set of how to
take that truth
and put it into a format that is a joke
and that's where i think it starts to
fall in like
like you're saying like you like you
lean into sarcasm more like oh maybe
that's
my style and that's how i convey
the things i want to say not just like i
i look back at my early years of comedy
i know like oh this
was a setup and a punchline it did
nothing about me
it was just a joke and then
you you you figure out that
it's more rewarding for me i find it
more rewarding to like
oh my my personal experience is like
well we're laughing at my personal
experiences
not punching down but like i get to talk
about myself i think that's what voices
like
internalize all the minutia again i
always use the go to the store example
because it's easy but you're like i went
to the store
how were you feeling when you were at
the store how
what mood were you in what music was
playing that made your mood that way
or changed your mood like that's how the
story becomes
funny is all the minutia that you get to
internalize and process yourself there's
you know the physical events don't have
to be funny
you know what are you processing why are
you buying what you're buying at the
store
what weird combo of things are you
buying at the store
there's nothing to do with what happened
in the parking lot of the store it's
just
all more [ __ ] to throw on
instead of writing a brand new joke
about
some entirely separate occurrence in
your life like no i went to the store
here's 20 minutes about there's so many
words to choose from
and i am always following the rut i
curse too much you could say the same
sentence
ten different ways with with a thesaurus
and why i don't want to ever do it to
sound pretentious it's just like
again it's like well you got different
shirts you can put on every day
well you like you know well that's why
not why
why not change it up just because then
it's fun to say then it's like it's like
you're more excited to say a bit because
you've got a new silly word to put in
if i'm not making it to the next level
maybe i didn't earn that yet maybe i'm
not putting the work in
i blame myself first before blaming
anybody else and what is always jealous
[ __ ] talking but right still is there
still jealousy for you
oh all the time yeah wow but it doesn't
do it doesn't do me any good
because you know people get netflix
specials people get
you know and it's like all right
and what am i going to do right
about it man it doesn't it it it exists
jealousy always exists and i'll [ __ ]
about it around people i know i can
[ __ ] about it around right but then the
the end result i was like
what are we gonna what i have a career i
tell jokes for a living
what like why i got the thing
you know yeah if you're serious about
becoming a comedian
join our facebook group linked in the
description below to start getting tips
like these
every single day and watch this playlist
of our top writing tips to improve your
writing today